now you say it was developed in the late
20s and early 30s by
dr victor frankel in vienna now what is
dr frankel's relationship to other
vietnamese psychiatrists such as sigmund
freud
well dr franco was a student of dr
alfred adler
yes who in turn was a student of dr
sigmund freud
so there's sort of an apostolic
succession here well it's sort of global
therapy is sort of the grandchild
of psychoanalysis i see now what
especially does
dr frankel say that perhaps differs from
freud or adler
well freud says among many i mean i have
to simplify this
yes freud says that the main
motivation for living is the pursuit of
pleasure
the pleasure the pleasure of the
president the pleasure we have a will
to pleasure and if this will the
pleasure is repressed
then we become neurotic and adler
agreed with this but went a step further
and said not only the will to pleasure
is important but also the will to power
that's sort of some of the concept back
of the nazi movement isn't it that this
will to power is something that people
have
and it was pushed out from that well the
it's it's more
uh perhaps the nietzsche
which is of course the nazi movement
picked it up on a
in an unhealthy way and the logotherapy
and abra picked it up in a helicopter
yes all right there's certainly a
therapeutic way of this will to power as
well
yeah well we all grow up as powerless
little children
surrounded by giant adults yes and all
our life
out of thought we are striving to
overcome this inferiority complex and
yes and this is part of our striving
for to achieve something yes now frank
so frankel is something different from
either of these well frankl accepts both
pleasure is pleasurable power is
important but pleasure is only important
as a
if you don't go after it directly power
is important
i mean pleasure is important as a
byproduct after having found meaning you
feel
pleasurable you feel pleasure in other
words frankel's first principle then
is not pleasure or power but meaning
yeah the
the will to meaning is instead of is the
main motivation for living
and for acting we want to find meaning
in our lives
but life today is so full of
full fear thanks fear of war fear of uh
being a hostage in iran fear of losing
your mate
there are so many fears how how does
this principle of finding
meaning and relationship hold up under
conditions of stress
for instance in frankel's old life did
it hold up under a condition of stress
well it not only holds up in conditions
of stress but it is absolutely necessary
in conditions of stress
and this is why we all of us are much
more concerned this meaning
now than we were in freud's time in
freud's time we were
concerned with sex and his pleasure
because this was repressed
now sex is not repressed so much anymore
but meaning is repressed
now in this theory of logotherapy
how do you get the meaning what
techniques do you use
there are so many people nowadays that
say i cannot help myself because my
mother
did this or my father did this my father
wasn't alcoholic my mother never loved
me i grew up in
in these terrible situations now there
is nothing that you can do to change
your past but again there is something
you can change your attitudes too it's
the past you can either
let the past drag you down or you can
take it as a challenge
and learn from it from this experience i
remember there was a woman who
who said my mother never loved me
therefore i cannot love
anybody and she was very isolated very
lonely and she had
no her excuse was her mother never loved
her so she could never lie and during
the local therapeutic therapy
she was she was led to to change this
attitude from my mother never loved me
therefore i
unable to learn i am unable to love to
the new attitude my mother
never loved me therefore i know how
painful it is not to be loved
and they make a special effort not to
spread this unlovingness any further
so you see the situation is the same
mother never laughed in either case but
attitude either was to say
i have to be lonely or i make a special
effort to reach out
so we can't change our heredity and we
cannot change
the environment that produced us but we
can change our
attitude toward this and we can change
what we are doing about this today
this is the message of local therapy
therapy
by meaning by relationship that you are
not
just a helpless product
of circumstance that you can do
something to change your life
whatever your circumstances i wonder
what this
sort of thinking would say to so much of
what is being preached in america today
for instance by robert ringer who writes
a book you're number one
and who emphasizes do your own thing
pursue your own interests pursue your
own needs and sort of really
who cares about anybody else i'm number
one
what would local therapy say to this
point of view well
excuse me um i think first of all
the idea he has is a good one and i
think we all need to learn to take care
of number one and to pursue our own
interest
however no man is an island we all need
to have each other in order to survive
and we all need to have our support
systems if you will and this is where
log of
therapy fits in so beautiful because
logo therapy
is a support system something that we
can turn to that we can find comfort in
and through logotherapy reach help us to
reach out to other people if we've had
that difficulty before
and i'm sure if anyone has gone through
the experience of
i'm number one i'm out for me i'm not
going to you know this person that's
their problem if they're suffering
i think very soon they'll find that
they've isolated themselves and become
very lonely and they don't have much
meaning in their life
because you do need to have other people
in order to find meaning
so it's important to have a caring for
yourself but it's important to move
beyond that to these relationships that
you're issued
exactly therapy stresses
the choice if you have a choice you will
find meaning
if you feel if you're in a situation
where you feel you have no choices you
are trapped you will feel meaningless
so it's very important in groups or in
local therapy in general
if you feel trapped to list all the
choices that you still have
but and this is where the number one
comes in
i can do whatever i want i make i have a
choice and so i do whatever i want
but frankly stresses that the choice
isn't enough
the the reverse side of the choice is
responsibility
you have to use your choice but it with
a sense of responsibility with a
responsibleness
and his idea is responsibility really
responsibleness in a
in a literal sense life is asking us
something every moment
we and we have to respond to the meaning
potentials of the moment
now we are all here in the same
situation but each of us has
a diff it's a different demand is is uh
is asked for us the meaning of the
moment for me
is to explain logo therapy for you it is
to draw me out
for for pennies to to tell something
about what it means to a nurse and
every one of you listeners will find a
different meaning some of you may be
intellectually
interested some of you may hope that
something that we say will help you in a
problem
uh some of you will find that hope that
we say something it
will help to some for somebody that you
care about
and if you make a choice you have to
respond
to this meaning of the moment that is
offered to you you have to
really risk being response able to
respond
and this is i think where where this
doing your own thing
falls short if you don't if you just do
it
regardless of what it happens to others
i can respond very much to that
sense of that when i don't have a sense
of choice i feel the meaning goes out of
life
yes that i get trapped into situations
where i find
i i get out my little appointment book
and everything's booked up there
and there's no room for anything anymore
there's only responding in that moment
to that person and the next one who's
coming
and i'm very conscious that i had my own
need to set aside one day a week
as a sabbath one day a week in which i
could really do what i wanted to do
that i could make the choices for that
day instead of having choices imposed
upon me
and i gather it's that sort of making
space to for your own affirmation
and your own ability to choose your own
relationships
that is part of what local therapy is
saying well
this this brings us to to something
which is perhaps the center point of
logotherapy
when he says franco says that we always
have choices
under all circumstances we all are free
to
choose and the reasons why he can say
this is because he
includes in this freedom of choice not
only the freedom
to choose to change the situation from a
meaningless situation to a meaningful
situation
but where this is not possible there is
one choice that nobody can ever take
away from us and this is the choice of
our attitudes
we can take a meaningful attitude
towards a meaningless situation
we can have several attitudes for a
meaningless situation there are
innumerable uh case histories that i
could
tell you about where were completely
of a change of
life comes about by a change of
attitudes
i see some similarity between some of
frankel's thought here and some of the
thought that comes to us from eastern
religions
i think especially of a famous zen
buddhist story now
where the monk is chased by a ravenous
tiger the tiger comes leaping after the
monk
and the monk falls over a cliff
and he looks down below him and there is
another
ravenous tiger and he looks up above him
and here
is the ravenous tiger and he's hanging
on
to a little bush and the bush
is just loose and it may come at any
time
and he sees one strawberry growing on
the bush
and he reaches up and he picks the
strawberry
and he eats it and says how delicious
i gather this would be similar to what
frankel would recommend
in such a circumstance well i suppose
with someone
i think he would he would go beyond that
and would say all right the strawberry
is beautiful but how do i get out of
this situation oh he would also deal
with getting out of it all right but
you were right there is a great
similarity between eastern religion and
and franklin was between western
religion and frankly when was when
franklin was in japan
they always tell them oh what you are
telling us we know from the
from from our sense and from our from
our scriptures
it's old stuff and when he was in
america his people said
what you're doing is quite new it's
quite different from freud
so he said he's quite quite happy about
that he has something which is
old and proven and still something new
so so it's interesting that some of the
ideas of logotherapy
seem to be very much akin to the old
teachings of this
eastern religion but quite new and
different from some of the
proposals and therapeutic methods put
forward by
sigmund freud it is rooted in common
sense and i think this is what makes it
valuable in other words it's rooted in
what really works
now i notice you mentioned the use of
local therapy in prisons i
recall in your book you mentioned a
visit of victor frankel to san quentin
prison would you tell us a little bit
about what happened there
well i i had arranged frankel's visit
and there was a speaking tour and we had
we had mapped out a schedule
he was here only three days and there
was a speak a speech every day and there
was television interviews and there were
a lot of things to be done and the
second day
when he was he spoke in marin county
our authority director of san quentin
came to him and said that one of his
prisoners
had read dr frankl's book man's search
for meaning
and it had changed his whole outlook of
life
and he had heard that frankel was in the
area whether frankly could possibly make
time to visit him and talk to him and to
our great consternation frankly
overthrew the entire
schedule that we had mapped out and made
the room had made time to go
to san quentin and i went with him and
it was an unforgettable experience
because he talked to that prisoner
and the result of this this talk to the
prisoner
the next time he came it was arranged
that he talked to
all the prisoners that wanted to hear to
hear him
so i was with him in san quentin twice
and i have described this in my book
that had had quite a
a great insight in what prisoners
like to like to do with their lives that
was the first time that
that some psychologist came to the to
the prisoners and
instead of telling them you are doomed
because you have this
terrible upbringing your parents were
neglecting you you grew up in slams your
islams and your societies against you
he was a man who said and this is again
the message of logotherapy regardless of
what your
background is or what your your your
drawbacks are
you have it within you to take a stand
against this drawback that's why he
called
this last speech he gave in in november
the defiant power of the human spirit
sort of a promethean
thrust here you're going to hold up your
courage to the gods it was very
important for the prisoners for to hear
that they still
in their terrible situation they still
have some power left to change their
lives if they want to yes well this
again is an affirmation
like in his own experience of the
concentration camp that in any
circumstances you have
at least the choice of your attitude to
these circumstances
and again he was very effective because
these prisoners knew that
he was he had been in the same situation
he not only was in prison he was in the
in the shadow of a gay gas chamber as
they were
so the human spirit is beyond the givens
of the pleasure principle
beyond simply seeking power and
overcoming inferiority
but is on a constant quest for meaning
and relationship
for our guests today we have had two
people who are very concerned with that
quest for reason
meaning and relationship penny parsons
the vice president
of the institute for local therapy and
dr joseph fabry the director of the
institute for local therapy
i'd like both of them to have just a few
seconds for a closing comment whatever
they'd like to say
first penny yes i think the most
important thing about logotherapy is
it's really a way of living and what we
do is help provide the tools
for people to to have a better life
thank you penny
well what i'm very often say that
logotherapy
at least the way we apply it is not so
much for the mentally sick
but for the mentally searching so this
is a therapy
for well people as well it's people for
well people who feel empty
frustrated trapped in transition periods
but basically not not sick in the in the
strictest sense
thanks again to dr joseph fabry and
penny parsons of the institute of local
therapy
one lawson road kensington california
94707 i'm dick volkey
saying thank you for being with us on
east bay live